nicht umsonst ist pizza eines der
beliebtesten gerichte der welt heute
will ich den inbegriff der italienischen
pizza zubereiten eine pizza napoletana
[Musik]
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch ich habe
einmal für jumbo schreiner eine pizza
mit salsa picante gemacht und heute will
ich diesen klassiker aus dem süden
italiens wieder zu bereiten und mir
richtig viel zeit dafür nehmen
[Musik]
selbstgemachtes thatcher ein besonderer
tag und ganz viel liebe
genau genommen ist das was ich hier
mache zwar keine cia sondern nur die
masse die in die brust getötet würde
aber da ich sie sowieso zum anbraten
herausrücken würde speicher diesen
schritt
[Musik]
ich habe auch heute das fleisch vor den
läufen in die gefriertruhe gegeben weil
das skater ist und man so noch bessere
ergebnisse erzielt
[Musik]
und los geht's
dieser kleine schrift das fleisch selbst
zu wollen und nicht gehäuft zu kaufen
macht gefühlt schon unheimlich viele
geschmack auf und es lohnt sich jedes
mal
[Musik]
weil ich wirklich gerne späße habe ich
nicht mit scharfer paprika und chili
gegeizt
fenchelsamen meersalz und ein wenig
wasser
[Musik]
alles gut mit dem gehäuften fleisch
verkneten
[Musik]
andrücken abdecken
und das war's ab
wir sehen uns erst wieder wenn es zeit
ist die pizza zu belegen
[Musik]
ich war extrem italienischen supermarkt
um die authentischen zutaten sozusagen
gemeint eine schicht drei verschiedene
mail
[Musik]
jedes hat seine eigene stärke
so wird der teig knusprig knuffig und
kriegt genau die richtige konsistenz
[Musik]
ich halbiere die mischung und mache
zunächst die biege also dem vorteig
fertig
[Musik]
mehl wasser hefe
mehr als das und eine nacht
zimmertemperatur braucht es nicht
[Musik]
die hefe im wasser auf
und alles zusammen
[Musik]
das ganze kann ich relativ grob zusammen
und dann mache ich erst mal feierabend
leute
[Musik]
der teig ist wirklich wunderbar
aufgegangen und glaubt mir wenn ich sage
dass die ganze wohnung gelüftet hat als
ihn aufgedeckt haben
jetzt mehr als einen halben tag später
kommt der rest des mehls ins spiel
doch erstmal muss ich ein bisschen mehr
sei es in wasser auflösen
ich vertrete alles gut und lassen an den
teig für 20 minuten abgedeckt
[Musik]
lois genug zeit dass sich die
feuchtigkeit den tag verteilt und wir
die letzten schritte einleiten können
währenddessen ist genug zeit für einen
espresso und ein paar leckere backwaren
aus dem italienischen super
ich schaffe es wirklich nie nur das zu
kaufen was ich mir vorgenommen habe wenn
ich im italienischen supermarkt
[Musik]
an dieser stelle nochmal ein großes
charlotte venture der mich inspiriert
hat diese videoreihe ein bisschen weiter
zu denken meinen eigenen stempel
aufzudrücken
aber der natürlich die ganz große in die
ganz große inspiration hinter diesem
videos ist und ein zweites tor von erik
weiß einfach wieder viel zu lang
aussieht
[Musik]
wenn ich den teig zu einer kugel geformt
habe lasse ich ihn noch mal zwei stunden
ruhen
dann ist es soweit ich fühle den teig
und formel kleine runde teig bildchen
daraus
und die warten jetzt noch mal ein paar
stunden darauf gebacken zu werden
jetzt wird es zeit für die finalen
vorbereitung
erst mal ein paar feine streifen rote
zwiebel schneiden
[Musik]
für unsere soße brauchen wir nichts
weiter als tomaten und salz
[Musik]
nicht mal ein mixer
diesen trick hat mir der pizza
weltmeister verraten dass man die
tomaten am besten von hand zerkleinert
damit man die kerne die zerstört
das würde die tomatensoße nämlich bitter
[Musik]
den büffel mozzarella zürich und lass
dich abtropfen damit unsere pizza nicht
verbessert
dazu noch kleine stückchen pro bowl ohne
[Musik]
anbraten
die gewürze sind tief eingezogen und
beim anbraten durfte die gesamte küche
[Musik]
unser teig ist lustig und weich
nach der langen zeit richtete fast ein
bisschen wie martin
[Musik]
tomaten sauce drauf
sowohl ohne
[Musik]
und wirklich
aber auf den schienen
[Musik]
das eigentliche backen gefahren sind
schnell
keine fünf minuten und das bei all der
vorbereitung
[Musik]
ein zweimal wenden
und all das
[Musik]
für einen moment
was soll ich sagen dieses feature ist
endstufe wir haben wirklich sehr sehr
gut getroffen pizza verneigt sich müssen
sie ein portfolio essen und pizza ist
sowas wenn du die sache viel zeit gibt
es gibt dir doppelt so viel zurück und
dieser lang gegangene teig der wirklich
gelüftet hat der wirklich wolkig ist und
alles in allem
[Musik]
mal wieder das perfekte beispiel dafür
warum man sich nicht immer aber manchmal
richtig viel zeit nehmen sollte dann
kommen danke fürs zuschauen und mal
schauen was uns das nächste sein